I was talking to Kevin Durant about how
I was doing this interview and he said
that he had a question okay are you
going to drop a snippet of you all song
on the radio
[Laughter]
show why would KY do that because see
that was on the rap that was on the low
see KD you messed up now that you done
that I just want you to know you messed
up and that song was being considered to
be on Carter 6 and I since you didn't
say something it's not
going now that you ruined it no uh no
I'm not playing to sniff it because I
just told the people how important the
song get the first is it actually was
supposed to go on KY Grove album with me
in two chains that just came out but I
saved it I want for something else what
is he like as an artist KD is a jewel
you know like something of the past
because he's a backpack rapper I can
imagine you probably could call a
timeout in the game and probably ask him
to rap and he probably got a verse for
you K he probably just got bars and it
sounds like it